what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting shoot
to a buzzfeed video
called 33 questions white people have
for white people
i thought who better to answer
questions for white people than the
whitest girl on earth
i can't think of anyone better anyways
before i start do not forget to like
comment and subscribe
i think i'm getting close let me check
to 15 000 subscribers
um yeah i need like 500 more that's my
next goal
i'm not gonna lie i don't have anything
cool that i'm doing for it
um if you guys could think of something
cool i could do let me know in the
comments but
i've thought nothing all right let's
33 and i'm gonna pause it and just
answer them all the other races like
fried
okay let me go why do you assume only
other races like fried chicken
i love fried chicken it should be a
white person stereotype because of me
i'm not the biggest fan of fried chicken
it's just okay
why do we make it so we only have
pumpkin in the fall i want pumpkin all
the time
that's a valid question
why do we only have pumpkin in the fall
i bet you it's because it's seasonal i
bet you that's why but starbucks is
pumpkin like
spice stuff i could drink year round
most white people dance seriously like
is it genetic or something do we have
like stiff hips or like two left feet
i can dance that's why okay this is hard
to
stop i also cannot dance
actually i take it back i can do like a
shimmy
you know what i mean i can shimmy so
you could say i'm a pretty big it's
whatever you get so annoyed when other
people don't speak english
english is hard we have silent k's
okay i don't get annoyed when other
people can't speak english but i'm very
bad at understanding accents
so i'll have to say what like 30 times
we get so excited to brag on instagram
that we went to this really cool
authentic cultural festival
even though we went with all of our
white friends why i don't go to
festivals
i literally the idea of like being a
loud
outdoor no not for me anyway people
spray tan until they turn orange
i don't know i seriously don't know
i have gotten a spray tan once or twice
but i i really don't go that dark i will
say you do look better tan
like you look thinner like instead of a
diet get a spray tan i guarantee it'll
look like you lost at least like five to
ten pounds
but as you can see i'm very pale
can't you just be comfortable in your
own body i'm just saying
it's not tan it's orange why do you
think that since you've seen five
seasons of the warrior you're a cultural
expert i've never heard of that movie
why do you believe
everything you see on tv when it comes
to other races
i don't okay how do we get upset when a
tv show becomes diverse
even though diverse usually just means
two to three people of color
i literally don't care who they cast why
do you assume movies with white stars
are automatically more relatable than
movies with people of color
people what i don't
color have had to relate to white
characters for all of cinematic history
i don't even watch movies like i swear
to god i watch youtube
viola davis the first black woman to win
an emmy for best actress why aren't we
complaining
that the oscars and other award shows
are like all white it's just like
i don't watch the oscars like white
people congratulating other white people
on being white everybody should be
represented why don't we know the
difference between appropriation
and appreciation appropriation and
appreciation
because not everyone has the same
definition like
some people like not everyone has the
same definition of appropriation
can we figure out how to make our own
pop culture our own slang our own cool
clothes instead of stealing other
people's cool clothes and then saying
that they are our cool clothes
why you know i'm gonna be honest like
i just watched videos and t-shirts man
why are white people obsessed with wes
anderson why would you ever say
i seriously don't know who that is thug
life it's a bad
life what i've never said you have
against seasoning and spiciness
i'm a bad cook i'm not even gonna lie my
mom did not teach me
i'm sorry she didn't christopher
columbus discover america looking for
spices
casserole did he really think why do you
try to avoid
confrontation at all costs okay
these are fast so i'm having a hard time
stopping it
casseroles they're fire i don't care
what anyone says about it
my mom makes a mean casserole and you
will not tell me otherwise
why do i avoid confrontation because i'm
awkward point in case
that's why why is it crazy that i'm
white and i'm a big butt why do you make
such a big deal when somebody doesn't
want to hike
okay i literally don't think that anyone
thinks it's crazy
that you have a big butt in your way i
think
nobody cares uh second thing
i don't know why my mom my family is
definitely the type of family to shame
you if you don't hike
i once got roped into hiking ten
thousand feet
ten thousand do you guys know how high
that is i don't even really like hiking
but i do think that like you have some
responsibility to like
be with nature a little bit especially
as you get older
why do you keep talking about reverse
racism that is not a thing
we are the people i've literally never
talked about it people in power
racism is about oppression sorry white
people have not been oppressed why are
you too afraid to speak up when someone
says something racist
why do i'm not i really am not
we think that having one friend of color
means that nothing we say or do could
possibly ever be racist
i don't you can absolutely say racist
things
when you have black friends why does
being half white
automatically make my commentary on
white culture only half
true he looks
oh i am just as much white as i am
mexican why do you believe that black
lives matter
means that your life doesn't matter
every life
matters it's just that one has a harder
time living
why do you get offended when you see a
table full of black people
but not when you see a lunch room full
of white people
am i the only one like i'm not offended
by any of this why do you always ask to
have a white people club
you already do it's a student union it's
primarily white they have a black
student union because you don't
represent them well
why do you i have never asked for a
white person club
i have asked for an irish club though i
think that would be fire
i mean hear me out hear me out
a room full of gingers i just can see it
i have a vision in my head
i've always wanted to like just have a
room full of gingers but
see the success of people of color as a
threat to you you know that a two minute
video about whiteness isn't reverse
racism right
two minutes about whiteness hundreds of
years of systemic oppression yeah i
think we can deal with this
why are we upset about immigrants when
we were the first immigrants
and we were white people running away
from other white people
i'm like not upset about immigrants at
all that kind of shows you how bad white
people can be
okay um
i don't know if this should i upload
this i will
okay please don't cancel me i thought
it'd be funny to react to them
um that was a buzzfeed
video
i don't like it when they like
automatically
assume you think something just because
of the way you look
but i am the whitest girl on earth so
that's my take let me know if you agree
with me or disagree in the comments
don't forget to subscribe get me to 15
000 this week guys